depuis plusieurs jours ce tandem
enchaîne les tours de piste sur le
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
raphaël bougies et athlètes touchées par
un handicap visuel eliane dujarrier du
club de vélizy 78 doivent peaufiner les
derniers détails avant de s'envoler pour
les championnats du monde handisport
programmée au brésil les 22 et 23 mars
pour l'instant ça fonctionne plutôt pas
mal après faut encore qu'on apprenne à
se connaître c'est comme un bas comme un
couple est plus là bas il ya le côté
sportif faut qu'on se règlent bas sur
les braquer et tout ce qui va avec quoi
pédaler à deux dans le même sens une
nouvelle expérience pour ian dujarrier
ce sportif benoît de 41 ans vice
champion du monde masters s'est associé
à ce projet avec l'équipe de france
depuis le mois de janvier
c'est très valorisant pour moi de me
dire que ben voila je peux être
accompagné quelqu'un et aider quelqu'un
à réaliser ses objectifs et a réalisé
des choses qu'il n'aurait pas pu faire
si l'ipad avec moi comme je vais à
l'entraînement aux entraînements que je
peux faire tout seul je les fais plus de
la même manière c'est vrai que je
m'entraîne pour lui je m'entraîne plus
pour moi et ça c'est autre chose
après une première expérience en
championnat de france handisport en
janvier couronné par une qualification
mondiaux les deux athlètes espère
désormais passer un cap au niveau des
résultats et s'aligneront sur la vitesse
et le kilomètre on espère pouvoir entrer
dans les dix ce qui nous permettrait de
marquer des points
au niveau au niveau mondial et ensuite
il faudrait qu'on passe dans les huit
premiers pour pouvoir accéder au tournoi
final
et là ce serait la cerise sur le gâteau
il premières échéances internationales
avant de viser le graal pour une athlète
handisport les jeux paralympiques de
tokyo en 2020